deux casques bleus tués hier soir par
des tirs d'artillerie serbe à sarajevo
pour ce journal la réaction de charles
millon le ministre de la défense alors
que l'on a appris la décision de
déployer à sarajevo les premiers
éléments d'artillerie de la force de
réaction rapide et que les serbes
poursuivent leur offensive autour de
l'enclavé de biatch autres titres
l'arrivée cet après midi sur les champs
elysées à paris du tour de france les
gars l'hymne du rennais le premier
coureurs dans l'histoire du cyclisme a
remporté cinq fois de suite que la
grande boucle en fin de journal nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur cet exploit en
compagnie du champion espagnol les aussi
de l'an jalabert et de bernard guillet
madame monsieur bonsoir à la sainte
brigitte indurain est au heat
le champion espagnol est en effet entré
dans la légende du cyclisme
rejoignant jacques anquetil eddy merckx
et bernard hinault
pour la petite histoire c'est l'ouzbek à
jude apatow qui a remporté le dernier
sprint sur les champs-elysées
récit de cette dernière étape thierry
clos ils étaient 115 ce matin sur cette
dernière étape en ile-de-france 115 sur
les 189 au départ à saint brieuc avec
une fois encore le souvenir du défunt de
fabio casartelli un peloton qui a
musardé jusqu'au tout premier tour sur
les champs elysées c'est à ce moment
précis que ça comme capoue judiciaire
pellini ouchakov le vainqueur de l'étape
allemande mme angela mejias décide de
prendre la poudre d'escampette
ce groupe d'échappés contrat jusqu'à 30
secondes d'avancé sur le peloton emmené
le plus souvent par l'équipe telekom du
sprinter zabel mais à un kilomètre de
l'arrivée le peloton galvanisés par
cette fan tour absorbe à quelques mètres
de la concorde
les échappés et sept au sprint
finalement que cette 20e étape va se
jouer c'est l'ouzbek abdul jabbar up qui
avait chuté sous les bulles il ya quatre
ans sur ce même champs elysées qui
l'emportent devant l'italien fanning un
autre italien lombardie et le français
laurent jalabert au classement final
premier ou du renne maillot jaune avec
quatre minutes 35 d'avancé hausse de
6,47 sur le danois
les trois font plus d'un mètre 85 il
fallait être particulièrement grand
cette année pour monter sur le podium
le soleil étant de la partie une foule
très importante a assisté à ce final du
tour 95 croquis signé thierry kurt et et
anne christine 30 il n'y en avait que
pour indurain les champs elysées aux
couleurs sang et or espagnol à cent
mille huit cent mille peut-être un
million de personnes venues voir le
monument le plus vil et le 23 juillet le
tour de prend les armes de l'aficionado
ce la patience l'ingéniosité il escalade
on était discours de bienvenue est là
dussault échanges à venir
au moment où il arrive je pages aux
élèves de quelques centimètres et d'une
magnifique vision vous suffit simplement
de talent et le vélo ça sert à nous
c'est ma vie une position sinéquanone il
faut être organisé cinq heures
d'attentes un thermos pour les glaçons
un autre pour l'eau un troisième pour le
rosé j'ai traîné donc on les voit
longtemps ainsi ils assisteront mieux
qu'en direct à la dernière facétie de
richard virenque le meilleur grimpeur du
tour a échangé sa monture avec un motard
de la gendarmerie nationale
spectacle complet c'est sûr ils
reviendront ambiance surchauffée à
l'ambassade d'espagne à paris où le
champion doit passer une partie de cette
soirée
sur place nous retrouvons jean rené
godart oui bruno nous sommes dans un des
salons de l'ambassade d'espagne situé à
300 mètres des champs elysées et dans
quelques minutes l'infante d'espagne
elena arrivera ici à l'ambassade
d'espagne et présidera donc cette
réception il y aura également plusieurs
membres du gouvernement de monsieur
felipe gonzalez cela c'est pour la
partie officielle
et puis il ya bien sûr la fête la fête
avenue marceau et avenue georges 5 ou
donne l'ambassade d'espagne et vous le
voyez d'emilie
deux supporters espagnols qui se sont
regroupés qui agite dépens de rock des
drapeaux espagnols qui chante aussi à la
gloire de miguel des musiciens venus
spécialement pour fêter le champion
espagnol reste une ambiance de fête
il faut dire qu'avec cinq tours de
france ligue l indie games dit miguel
indurain est entré dans l'histoire et
après avoir de nouveau découvert ces
images je pense que nous le retrouverons
dans quelques minutes
ici même à l'ambassade est tout à
l'heure absolument j'en ai répété bien
votre révérence pour l'un font tout à
l'heure cinq victoires sur les cinq
derniers tours miguel indurain aurait pu
être l'invité de 5 sur 5 présenté par
jean rené godart j'ai envie d'avoir de
profiter de cette victoire
cette cinquième victoire cela était déjà
tellement dur de me préparer et de
gagner cinq rangs record dont je suis
fier comme l'ont fait et non au petit
lait et merckx avant moi maintenant
j'espère pouvoir beaucoup me préparer
pour revenir l'année prochaine avec l'
envie de gagner un sixième tour ce
serait vraiment magnifique l'ast
journaliste hausse les journalistes
disent que vous êtes mégalithes du renne
au panthéon du sport quand pensez-vous
porte au panthéon c'est vous dire je
suis à la hauteur de certains grâce à ce
record mais il me manque d'autres
grandes épreuves à mon palmarès comme le
tour d'espagne ont le championnat du
monde pour atteindre le panthéon
atteindre le plus haut niveau
nous reviendrons bien évidemment en fin
de journal sur la fin de cette grande
boucle 95 et sur l'exploit digne du
renne en compagnie du champion et
d'autres invités notamment laurent
jalabert ou bernard hinault auparavant
je vous propose de revenir bien sûr
longuement sur la dégradation de la
situation en bosnie de plus en plus
préoccupante
hier soir deux casques bleus français
ont été tués et trois autres blessés
dont un grièvement par des tirs
d'artillerie serbe contre un convoi
humanitaire et deux positions de la
forpronu à sarajevo
depuis le début du conflit en
ex-yougoslavie
43 soldats français ont été tués
françoise joly
une des cibles privilégiées des serbes
de bosnie cette piste du mont igman et
ses convois humanitaires qui ravitaille
sarajevo et casques bleus français sont
parmi les seuls à s'y risquer ils en
connaissent tous les dangers hier soir
des morts qui servent les ont visés
délibérément un casque bleu est mort un
autre a été grièvement blessé et cette
attaque n'était pas isolé de passe de
commandement de la forpronu au coeur de
sarajevo ont été pris sous le feu de
lance roquettes et de chars ferme et
c'est ici qu'un autre français un
médecin capitaine a été déchiqueté par
un obus nous sommes bien évidemment
révolté par le lâche assassinat le
double lâche assassinat de cette nuit
mais à côté ça notre détermination reste
grande
ne serait ce qu en la mémoire de ces
deux soldats qui sont tombés pour la
population sarajevo pour faire cesser
les tirs serbe la forpronu ripostera
elle aussi par un feu nourri darty les
qui lui faudra a menacé de représailles
palais le fief des serbes bosniaques
pour qu'un calme éphémère règne à
sarajevo quelques heures de répit et cet
après midi de nouveaux tirs d'obus
blessé cette fois ci trois personnes des
civils
moins de 48 heures après la conférence
de londres voici donc peut-être la
réponse des serbes de bosnie aux menaces
de frappes aériennes de l'otan
londres c'était satis et de menaces les
serbes bosniaques eux ont frappé blessés
et tués
on vient de le dire moins de 48 heures
après cette réunion de londres les
serbes de bosnie ne semble guère ému par
la nouvelle mise en garde de la
communauté internationale des
bombardements ont repris contre
l'enclavé orientale de j'ai pas et
surtout celle de biatch qui connaît
selon les responsables de la force onu
sur place une pression considérable sur
tous les fronts les troupes bosniaques
sont en quelque sorte pris en tenaille
entre les serbes de krajina en croatie
voisine
et les serbes de bosnie cette enclave
musulmane de gatx et la plus étendue de
bosnie deux cent mille personnes environ
ils sont actuellement regroupés
c'est en arrivant cette nuit à dakar que
jacques chirac a appris la mort des deux
casques bleus français
le président français a réagi ce matin à
cet événement dramatique sur le ton de
la fermeté
la conférence de londres a pris de
décision on savait qu'un méchant pas
tout à fait celle que nous avions
souhaité mais elle existe non elles
doivent être appliquées sans
atermoiements et sans faiblesse bien
renforts de moyens qui étaient gagés la
forpronu vient de demander à la force de
réaction rapide de se mettre en
situation d'intervention jouit que nous
ayons ces éléments d'action aujourd'hui
et les serbes doit bien comprendre que
nous ne subirons il y va à la fois
la survie des populations musulmanes de
bosnie il va de la dignité de la
forpronu et des forces alliées en baisse
des revenus des unités de la force de
réaction rapide ont reçu l'ordre
aujourd'hui de se déployer à sarajevo la
moitié du contingent français soit
environ 500 légionnaires ont été mises
en état d' alerte pour quitter l'ouest
de la bastille où ils sont regroupés à
destination de sarajevo avant d'entendre
les explications du ministre de la
défense charles millon
le reportage de gilles rabin et de
laurent habitat il attendait depuis plus
d'un mois et ce matin l'ordre est arrivé
l'ordre de faire mouvement vers sarajevo
aucune explication n'a été donnée aux
légionnaires simplement à 2 heures du
matin à l'état d' alerte a été
déclenchée pliage détente remise du
matériel dans les véhicules blindés les
hommes plaisante mais c'est le début des
choses sérieuses pour la légion dès 9
heures ils sont prêts à partir 9h23 pu
embarquer
or
bang dormir parce que les officiers de
l'état major doivent négocier le passage
de la colonne blindée à chacun des
checkpoints bosniaque qui jalonnent la
route vers le mont igman versa yahoo
certains en profitent pour s'informer
la négociation avec les bosniaques
durera toute la journée les premiers
éléments ne sait prendrons que vers 17
heures
nous retrouvons gilles rabin en direct
de split en croatie gilles première
question quel est l'objectif de ce
déploiement des légionnaires français
autour de sarajevo et bien que tu es
officiellement la légion reçu l'ordre de
venir soutenir toutes les positions de
casques bleus en difficulté au taux de
sarajevo il ya 500 les jeunes air mais
c'est surtout un renfort en puissance de
feu il ya beaucoup de canons des chars
amx des missiles antichars et des
obusiers de nouveaux hobbies y est de
120 mm alors la légion va se déployer
tout autour de sarajevo autour de
l'aéroport d'abord là où a eu lieu
l'attaqué hier autour de la ville
assiégée mais aussi autour de la piste
du mont igman c'est à dire partout où
des serbes attaque des positions des
casques bleus autre question qui selon
vous précisément à décider de ce
mouvement de troupes
écoutez la demande de renforts elle est
venue hier soir après l'attaqué qui a
fait deux morts deux blessés graves et
deux blessés légers du général
gobilliard le commandant en chef du
secteur de sarajevo et c'est le général
ce janvier semble-t-il le commandant en
chef des forces de l'onu pour tout l'ex
yougoslavie qui a décidé lui seul qui a
décidé d'envoyer de la force de réaction
rapide d'une partie de la force de
réaction rapide en renfort à sarajevo
merci gilles rabin de ces précisions les
500 légionnaire français vont être
appuyés par 400 artilleurs britannique
équipé de 12 canons de 105 mm reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux dorothée
olliéric alain duban pascal perrin
c'est en fin d'après midi que les
premières troupes et la logistique du
1er bataillon britannique des bananes de
recettes ont quitté vitez le quartier
général des forces britanniques
l'ordre est tombé très tôt ce matin les
soldats britanniques doivent retrouver
les soldats français pour sécuriser la
piste du mont igman le seul accès à
sarajevo le colonel jeff cooke a précisé
en début d'après midi que cette action
était la réponse directe à la mort hier
soir de deux casques bleus français à
sarajevo
rien à voir avec la conférence de
londres il s'agit bien ici d'une réponse
de l'onu à une agression contre l'onu
mais le commandement britannique a
également précisé que les forces
engagées dans cette opération ne ferait
foule sur les positions serbes camp
à de nouvelles menaces de leur part pour
entraver leur action charles millon
bonsoir merci d'être sur ce plateau ce
soir nous reviendrons dans un instant
sur les conditions de ce déploiement de
la force de réaction rapide tout d'abord
de questions sur le drame d'hier soir
après cette attaque dont ont été
victimes à nouveau des casques bleus
français qui a pris la décision de
répliquer tu dois te permettez moi de
saluer la mémoire de ces deux vielles
français qui sont tombés pour la survie
de la population de sarajevo et pour
l'honneur de la communauté
internationale de qui est venu l'ordre
on vient de vous le dire il est venu
comme ceux ci et avait été décidée à la
conférence de paris le 3 juin dernier il
est venu de la demande a été formulée
par le général gobilliard le commandant
de sarajevo pour les forces forpronu qui
a été relayée par général janvier qui
lui est le commandant de la force onu
pour toute la bosnie herzégovine et pour
tout la l'ex yougoslavie et a pas de ce
moment-là biais la force de réaction
rapide a répondu elle est composée d'un
contingent français et d'un contingent
britannique on vient de le rappeler
alors il réplique hier soir est ce que
vous savez si des batteries serbe visés
ont été neutralisés comme on dit et s'il
ya des victimes du côté des serbes
compte tenu de la riposte de la longueur
des échanges il est évident que les
batteries serbes ont dû subir un certain
nombre de dégâts mais vérifications ne
pourra être faite que dans les jours qui
viennent
le seul problème aujourd'hui qui est
posée c'est de savoir si on va résister
à l'agression serbe
la conférence de londres avait ce thème
là au centre de ses préoccupations
elle y a donné des réponses puisque j'ai
des réponses qui n'ont pas était tout à
fait satisfaisante pour la délégation
française puisque nous aurions aimé
aller beaucoup plus loin
nous avions proposé que les forces
terrestres puisse aller porter soutien
aux forces de l'onu à gorazde en
particulier mais il y a eu mais il ya eu
quand même une décision c'est de
riposter à toute agression serbe
on a aujourd'hui le cas pratiques
malheureusement elle nous constatons que
la force de réaction rapide et mobily
et et que deux aujourd'hui il y à
concertation entre les officiers
supérieurs français britanniques
américains pour décider de la mise en
oeuvre des modalités de riposte au
niveau 2 le temps est au niveau de
l'oeil nu à travers des bombardements
aériens par exemple précisément chamion
jacques chirac à dakar a menacé les
serbes de représailles parlant de
possibilité de détruire une caserne
alors est ce que on pourrait être amené
à bombarder des objectifs beaucoup plus
significatif que des batteries un peu
isolé dans les bois vous comprendrez ma
discrétion à ma réserve je ne vais pas
décrire les tactiques militaires
aujourd'hui des officiers généraux sont
réunis pour ce faire ils sont en train
d'analyser toutes les modalités
pratiques sur le terrain je suis sûr que
durant les jours à venir
on constatera que notre détermination
est totale et que pour nous il s'agit 1
de permettre à sarajevo de voir sa
sécurité et sa liberté de circulation
pour les personnes garantie de de
permettre aux forces de l'onu
d'accomplir leurs missions aux forces de
l'onu accomplir leur mission
et puis enfin et bien de montrer aux
serbes qu'il n'y a pas de solution
militaire qu'il ne peut y avoir qu'une
solution politique au problème
bosniaques et qui serait peut-être plus
sain au sens de l' équilibre de vie en
bosnie d'aller autour d'une table de
négociation que de continuer à faire des
haies crétion agression qui sont
totalement intolérable alors on vient de
le voir les premiers éléments de la
force de réaction rapide de marche
versailles et vous alors question très
précise ou vont-ils aller exactement
légionnaires foncé les artilleurs
britannique et pour faire quoi très
précisément est-ce qu'il vous restait
dans la ville où se déployer autour de
la vie sur les colis il ya actuellement
une seule voie pour desservir sarajevo
sur la voie du mouvman les troupes les
condamne le contingent français le
contingent britannique de la force de
réaction rapide vont rejoindre la piste
du mont igman pour permettre le maintien
du désenclavement de sarajevo pour
garantir éventuellement demain la
réouverture de l'aéroport de sarajevo et
pour empêcher que ça y est vous ne soit
pris en tenaille par des forces serbes
qui irait jusqu'à l'étouffement
donc il faut savoir que ses forces sont
très équipé votre correspondant l'a
rappelé qu'elles seront même renforcés
par des équipements qui sont partis de
france des canons 155 qui doivent être
arrivées sur place début août et qu'il
faut que les serbes ne se fasse aucun
aucun no kuni qu'il n'y a aucune
hésitation chez nous français chez ou
britanniques
nous résisterons à toute agression qui
serait mené par les serbes vis-à-vis de
sarajevo
pourquoi pas libérer la route principale
qui mène à seriez vous plutôt que de
prendre cette piste qui est un peu
hasardeuse et compliquée par le mont
igman c'est un plan que nous avons
décidé il y a quelques semaines car
c'est une piste qui permet l'accès des
convois humanitaires mais il est bien
évident que dans les semaines à venir
pour pouvoir effectivement désenclaver
sarajevo il faudra dix ans il faut
désenclaver sous l'angle aérien c'est à
dire permettre à l'aéroport à nouveau de
recevoir des avions et deuxièmement
caminel deac le désenclavement par voie
terrestre est apparu ce moment-là de
réfléchir désenclavement de la boîte de
christian-jaque toute la question
charles millon l'a dit actuellement une
offensive serbe contre les enclaves de
zepa et surtout de biatch on a le
sentiment là aussi que côté occidentaux
aux côtés des occidentaux
le sort de ces deux enclaves est en
quelque sorte passé pour pertes et
profits a déjà recueilli croix dessus
mais pas du tout il faut relire les
conclusions de londres elles sont
claires la communauté international
réagira à toute agression de la part des
serbes et il faut que les serbes se
sache pour dit il y aura en fait une
réaction d'un comité attac biatch on n'a
pas le sentiment que ça bouge beaucoup à
biatch il y a actuellement une agression
des serbes
aujourd'hui je voulais dit les officiers
généraux sont en train de décider des
modalités pratiques de mise en oeuvre de
l'avertissement de londres dans les
jours prochains
je souhaite je l'espère et je l'attends
il y aura de la réaction de la part de
la communauté internationale comme j'ai
pu constater hier encore on
s'interrogeait sur le caractère
opérationnel de la force de réaction
rapide
je crois que la réponse a été donnée
aujourd'hui merci chant millions pour
ces précisions
jacques chirac a achevé aujourd'hui à
dakar une tournée africaine de cinq
jours la première visite officielle à
l'étranger du nouveau président qui
avait surtout pour objectif de lutter
contre la fraude et civisme qui selon
lui a cours en occident actuellement
avec nos envoyés spéciaux jérôme cathala
et jacques gérard un premier bilan de
cette tournée africaine
les biens godeau les des châssis preuves
ont été mobilisés de même que les
groupes de danse représentatif des
différentes régions sénégalaises et la
population dakaroise rassemblés place de
l'indépendance pour accueillir le
président français comme hier au gabon
comme avant-hier en côte d'ivoire le
sénégal sont l'apprécié que jacques
chirac est réservée à l'afrique son
premier déplacement officiel à
l'étranger
une visite au cours de laquelle le
président de la république a rencontré
une quinzaine de chefs d'état africains
avec un message la france croient dans
l'afrique
symbole de la permanence des liens
franco-africains la présence de jacques
foccart ancien conseiller du général de
gaulle vous espérez que jacques chirac
suivra un petit peu la voix vous avez
trois siècles général de gaulle
en fait si les tenues vestimentaires de
jacques chirac sont parfois décontracté
il a tenu aux chefs d'état africains des
propos plutôt ferme sur la nécessité de
la rigueur économique et la poursuite
des processus de démocratisation en
france dans la région de redon gendarmes
et policiers recherchent très activement
le meurtrier de la petite karine cette
fillette de onze ans pour le corps a été
retrouvé hier matin 400 mètres du
domicile de ses parents
l'autopsié a en effet confirmé que ce
meurtre avait été accompagnée de
violences sexuelles le point de
l'enquète avec jérôme laurent et serge
le nom retrouvé samedi matin dans ce
bois le corps de karine âgé de 11 ans
est emporté quelques heures plus tard
sur un brancard destination
l'institut médico-légal de rennes où une
autopsie a été pratiquée et dansait déjà
je puis te de même vous dire qu'elle est
active que le meurtre de l'enfant a été
accompagnée des violences sexuelles
la disparition de karine remonte à
vendredi soir la jeune fille avait
décidé de passer son après midi à la
piscine de redon
à l'issue de son après midi ses parents
devaient la retrouver à 18 vers 18h la
reprendre mais elle est sortie un peu
plus tôt et ses parents n'étant pas là
elle a décidé de regagner seul à pied
son domicile
toujours sans nouvelles d'eux heures
plus tard ses parents alertent la
gendarmerie après une nuit de recherches
karine est retrouvé à cet endroit à
quelques centaines de mètres de son
domicile dans le lotissement où habite
les parents de karine la douleur est
évidemment très vives
là on est très motivé pour ce qui s'est
passé ton propre confort tout le
lotissement est bas sur dix ne sait
vraiment il est tranquille on n'a jamais
vu aucun problème dans ce lotissement
les enquêteurs continuent de questionner
le voisinage pour tenter de retracer
l'itinéraire emprunté par la fillette
une information judiciaire devrait être
ouverte dans les prochains jours par le
parquet de rennes nuits d'émeutes à
montataire dans l'oise après la mort
d'un jeune de 27 ans à la suite d'une
rixe avec une famille réputée violente
le reportage de florence bukiya
guillaume fautrat
et vraisemblablement le premier
responsable de la mort d'un jeune la
nuit dernière dans une cité de l'oise
il est ici arrêté mais surtout protéger
par des dizaines de policiers qui
empêchent une centaine de jeunes de la
cité de se faire justice
c'est dans cet appartement que le drame
s'est déroulé depuis des mois l'homme
s'en prenait aux jeunes des insultes en
les provoquant il y avait plusieurs
d'entre eux voulu régler leurs comptes
mais l'homme était tarn et une fois
l'appartement du meurtrier vider les
jeunes lemaitre hastac puis ils s'en
prennent aux policiers incendies aux
quatre de leurs voitures
la piscine de tabac la boucherie autant
de lieux qui suit également la rage des
jeunes de montataire continuerait
montataire petite ville brutalement
envahi par la violence et la peur et par
l'incompréhension car le meurtrier était
connu des services de police de
nombreuses plaintes avaient déjà été
déposées contre lui
retour à une actualité infiniment plus
souriante avec le triomphe de miguel
indurain entrée aujourd'hui dans le
carré d'as du tour de france celui des
quintuples vainqueurs de la course
cycliste la plus prestigieuse au monde
avec jacques cardoze un rapide rappel
des cinq glorieuses de miguel ange comme
le surnomme arlette chabot ce pourrait
être la même image mais cela fait bien
cinq ans qu'il se joue des tours de
france mètres de la course fort en
montagne
impérial dans les contre la montre
pourtant son physique de statues
grecques passerait presque inaperçu en
key account qui remporte l'étape du val
louron aux côtés de l'espagnol
indurain en os cette année là son
premier maillot jaune le premier d'une
longue série
illustration de sa suprématie l'année
suivante il rattrape fignon parti six
minutes plus tôt dans le
contre-la-montre du luxembourg il
termine à 55 km heure de moyenne
désormais il y à indurain et les eaux
les autres sa tribu les accessits
n'importe lesquels la chance pour le
navarrais en 93 cette chute aurait pu
tout changer
ce sera finalement qu'une anecdote mais
dans l'ascension d'isola 2000 robert
millar tente de s'échapper roaming
heures et indurain unissent leurs
efforts pour le rattraper opportunisme
de l'espagnol est ce une grimace ou un
sourire
luc leblanc s'impose devant indurain
mais il n'y a pas de danger au général
cette année il a fait la différence dans
le contre-la-montre de vassivière alors
quelle est la grande force du règne sans
doute de savoir s'économiser pour
l'année suivante
seul avant lui jacques anquetil eddy
merckx et bernard hinault avait réussi
l'exploit de gagner 5 grande boucle
mais le champion espagnol est le seul à
avoir remporté cinq victoires
consécutives en direct avec nous de
l'ambassade d'espagne bernard hinault
précisément l'un de ces lots quintuple
victorieux bonsoir bernard hinault
bonsoir comment jugez-vous le champion
une dure est né pour être plus précis
est-ce que c'est pas un peu une victoire
à l'économie merce avait remporté 34
victoires d'étapes au total vous 27 et
il dut rennes ont seulement pourrait-on
dire
je crois que l'important c'est de gagner
donc il faut savoir comme il disait tout
à l'heure il faut savoir s'économiser
c'est ce qu'il a fait depuis le départ
est à l'occasion ça lui permettra
d'aller encore un peu plus loin jean
rené godard ou justement c'est ça qui
est formidable c'est que miguel indurain
a gagné aujourd'hui son cinquième tour
de france il n'a que 31 ans est encore
un avenir au plus haut niveau il peut
espérer gagner une sixième fois l'an
prochain logiquement oui si les
adversaires qui sont là cette année sont
les mêmes
il a la possibilité de faire un sixième
de tour de france dont il faut pas
l'avoir l'accident faut pas le malade il
faut avoir plein de choses mais avec
tout ce qu'il a fait depuis un certain
temps il peut le faire
il peut le faire est finalement entré on
dit parfois parle parfois du panthéon du
sport ce serait le cas car vous le savez
gagné cinq tours c'est dur un sixième
sixième consécutif ce serait
extraordinaire exceptionnel oui et c'est
tout le mal qu'on peut lui souhaiter
je pense qu'il faut qu'il y en ait
toujours un devant aveux devant les
autres et pourquoi pas lui
voilà le témoignage de bernard hinault
bonheur merci beaucoup jour bruce
d'aller battre dans direct à au théâtre
de l'empiré retrouver le premier
français de ce tour 95
laurent jalabert quatrième donc qui a
ramené sur les champs-elysées le maillot
vert du meilleur classement par points
bonsoir
alors vous avez raté de peu le podium
est ce que c'est pour l'année prochaine
voire même la deuxième ou la première
place c'est un le bon je crois que cette
année je me suis bien battue sur sur à
peu près tous les terrains bon c'est
vrai qu'au départ du tour j'étais pas
non plus parmi les favoris pour le
général me retrouver quatrième
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est avant
tout les satisfactions mais
ça peut faire penser aussi que dans le
futur mais pourquoi pas viser plus haut
est-ce que c'est pas la plus mauvaise
place la quatrième place parce que vous
êtes juste à côté du podium
on dit que c'est la seconde c'est la
plus mauvaise mais c'est évident que
latrille mcc juste à côté du podium mais
bon c'est toujours mieux que 5e je crois
que nous quatrième place dans le tour de
france c'est très important est bon une
place et quelle qu'elle soit c'est
toujours important et ça se défend
merci laurent jalabert je vous pose à
tout seigneur tout honneur d'entendre
les confidences du vainqueur miguel
indurain confidences ceux recueillis par
jean rené godart dit merckx et il était
vraiment très fort il était très
puissant et je crois qu'ils avaient une
autre façon de courir plus il était en
forme toute l'année c'est pour ça que
finalement il a accumulé beaucoup de
victoires
bernard hinault il avait un caractère
vraiment différent du mien je crois
qu'il était plus expansif que moi et
puis l'eau s'il avait vraiment une autre
façon de courir et anquetil ben je n'ai
pas connu on me dit qu'il me ressemble
beaucoup je crois que il roulait
beaucoup il gardait ses distances
et c'est sans doute pour ça qu'il qui ne
me ressemblent un peu mais je crois
quand même que dans l'ensemble il ya pas
mal de différences entre nous c'est
vraiment une année importante pour une
cinquième victoire dans le tour et un
enfant
ah oui c'est vraiment une grande année
un enfant la cinquième victoire
tout cela en même temps c'est parfait et
c'est pour cela que je veux aller plus
loin et que je reviendrai faire un
nouveau tour c'est pour ma famille que
je fais tout ça est ce que la vie
familiale compte tant que cela pour vous
c'est oui c'est très important je fais
du vélo pour gagner ma vie bien sûr
parce que c'est ma profession mais je
fais tout ça aussi pour aider ma famille
voilà après le premier le dernier avec
un petit clin d'oeil à bruno cornillet
lanterne rouge de ce tour de france 95
propose de retrouver en toujours en
direct de lempire patrick chêne oui
alors nous ne sommes pas avec le dernier
mais les vues des premiers français donc
richard virenque est avec nous et
laurent jalabert voilà une image qui
vaut de l'or les deux premiers français
généralement on demande aux coureurs que
l'image qu'ils gardent du tour et bien
quand on vous en a parlé tout à l'heure
dans stade 2 notamment l'image qui
restait était bien sûr lié à fabio
casartelli et on ne peut pas évoquer ce
tour de france sans revenir sur le drame
qui a endeuillé le tour de france
quelques images
remporter l'étape cvo richard qui
gagnait le jour du décès de fabio ça
permet au peloton de démontrer quelque
chose qu'elle était capable d'avoir un
geste symbolique gratuit c'est à dire
que le peloton je pourrais considérer
que c'est comme une famille et ce jour
là on a perdu membres de la famille donc
tous les coureurs toute la caravane sur
tout le monde ne pense à sa famille
aussi devait être vraiment triste et de
ce qui s'était passé donc on est en
deuil et on lira rendu pendant 250 km un
hommage et c'est le moins qu'on pouvait
faire ce jour là alors vous êtes tous
les deux maintenant l'hérault on l'a vu
tout à l'heure on verra quelques images
furtives à la fin de cette séquence
vous avez été accueilli par le public
français est ce qu'il ya de la place
pour de ce qu'on va vivre un jour
ont-ils poulidor à une guéguerre entre
les deux leaders du cyclisme le français
laurent mais ce serait bon signe et je
crois que si on devait se faire la
guerre tous les deux ça veut dire que le
cyclisme français de bons éléments et
souhaitons le quoi qu'on puisse se
disputer un jour une victoire du tour
alors il faille à 36,15 virant que vous
êtes une vraie star dans le peloton
il ya de la place pour deux ça vous gêne
pas que laurent soit un petit peu plus
applaudi que vous cette année au pense
que la place pour beaucoup plus mais bon
il avait un avantage cette année qui
passe beaucoup plus dans sa région que
moi je passais dans la mienne donc mais
bon je pense qu'elle la place bourbon
beaucoup plus et si on est trois quatre
cinq qu'on peut être beaucoup populaire
en france et et la place pour beaucoup
plus de coureurs est bon qu'on soit 2
ben c'est comme ça voilà en tout cas on
est ravi de vous avoir proposé cette
image des deux vedettes du cyclisme
français
regardez l'image a eu lieu dans stade 2
et quelques instants elle et le public
de stade 2 l'ovation qu'il avait rendu à
ces deux champions est vrai mais c'est
un beau geste savon pour les terminales
surono
merci patrick nous allons repartir un
court instant à l'ambassade d'espagne où
on fait la fête ce soir et où jean rené
godard est en train de danser le
flamenco
oui bruno écouter pour l'instant il ya
toujours des milliers de personnes qui
sont devant l'ambassade
l'infante elena la fuite du roi juan
carlos est arrivé à 6 que les membres du
gouvernement mais miguel indurain vous
voyez ces gens qui sont massés le long
des grilles des liens en fait deux
entrées l'une avoue georges saint claud
avenue marceau des milliers de personnes
dont qui chante qui font la fête voyait
les différentes personnalités qui arrive
il y à perico delgado pedro delgado que
vous voyez en troisième position le
petit brun qui a gagné le tour en 1988
et qui a été ensuite le lieutenant digne
du renne
tous sont arrivés mais miguel indurain
n'est pas encore pour l'instant ici à
l'ambassade où la fête sera royal bien
sûr merci et la sangria va couler à
flots si j'osais la comparaison est
après tout aux où je dirais que le
festival de juan les pins et au jazz que
l'arrivée sur les champs-elysées au tour
le sommet de la saison hier soir
quelques privilégiés dont alban nicosie
et didier beaumont ont pu écouter dans
les pains de juan une légende vivante du
jazz soderling
miles davis et dizzy gillespie disparu
il est l'un des derniers colosse du jazz
sonny rollins est un magicien qui fait
du saxophone à l'instrument de fait la
synthèse entre le souffle puissant du
jazz et les influences antillaise et
afro cubaine
je peux faire cette transition si j'ai
apporté quelque chose de signifiant au
jazz c'est d'essayer de mieux accorder
tous ces éléments entrent à juan les
pins il a donné son unique récital
européen de l'été lui qui dit préférer
quelques rares grands rendez vous avec
le public à une approche plus
commerciale détourné pratiqués par
d'autres en cela aussi
sonny rollins est unique
bravo vers minuit dernier journal
présenté par florence dauchez bonne fête
aux brigitte dans un instant la météo de
nathalie rihouet météo qui se résume en
5 mots
températures en hausse soleil partout à
demain 20h avec cette question tout à
fait existentielle qu'allons-nous faire
l'après-midi maintenant que le tour est
terminé
à demain
et